since the this talking about realistic
polynomials and preservers so basically
we're going to see generalizations of
what Yann talked about in his in his
talk to multivariate polynomials so let
me get started so we say a polynomial P
with n variables even after the N is
real stable here Z 1 up to the n not
equal to 0 whenever I'm on up to the N I
mean H of n so what is H to the N so
what is H I'm going to use H to denote
the set of complex numbers with positive
imaginary value so these are sort of
complex numbers to see that the
imaginary value of C is positive ok so
so this definition means that P has no
roots in the upper half complex plane no
roots they're all of z1 up to Zn have
positive imaginary value ok so I agree
the first time I saw this definition it
didn't make any sense to me it seems
bizarre definition but hopefully like
one goal of this talk is to make this
more familiar to you so let me before
talking about examples I want to say an
equivalent definition this one makes
more sense and some people so says that
P is real stable for all vectors a you
know which are positive so every vector
that they're all coordinates are
positive and being R to the N 3 does not
have to be positive the univariate
polynomial
and T plus B is really so so it says
that in order to test a polynomial to be
real stable all you need to do is to
basically look at it along this line 80
plus B where a has all positive
coordinates and see if the corresponding
polynomial is rewritten so I want to
prove this and then I'll talk about
example so let me prove this very
quickly so there are two direction let's
prove the forward direction so suppose P
is real stable I want to prove that this
polynomial is real rooted
I do it by contradiction so so for a sec
of contradiction suppose P is not real
root by definition that exists say Z 1
up to the N part the imaginary value
there exists even up to Zn deposit
imaginary value now I want to construct
a and B so I define a J to be the
imaginary value of Z J and BJ to be the
real value of Z J because the eyes have
possibly imaginary value a J is positive
so this is that this vector satisfies
this this property and B is the real
vector now you can easily see that P of
Z 1 up to the N is equal to P of 80 plus
P so so this side so this is the root
side exists is the 1 up to Z and such
that P of Z 1 up to the anything is 0 so
Z 1 up to Z n is the root of P so this
is 0 and this is 0 as I said to me
oh yeah you're right that my assuming P
is not stable so so if I put T equals I
don't baby the imaginary value of one
these two are exactly equal so I get a
root with which is a complex root for
for this polynomial so P of eighty plus
P is not really tell and that's a
contradiction it's an original P so this
assumption is violet okay so now let's
prove the opposite direction so so now I
want to go from here to there so I wanna
assume that this polynomial is really
rooted I want to prove that the original
polynomial P is real stable now again
that's proved by contradiction so
suppose you're 80 plus P is not real
rooted or for some a the change is
positive and be real now what I want to
do is that I wanna I want to prove that
I want to prove that that the polynomial
the polynomial P is is not is not stable
yes so I'm gonna I'm gonna so so first
of all this is this is not real root ed
so there exists the complex root that
exists t which which is complex which
such that imaginary value of T is not
equal to zero now because this
polynomial has real coefficients the
roots come in conjugate pairs we already
started in the previous talk so so there
exists the root not only with nonzero
imaginary value that exists the root
with the imaginary value positive now
I'm going to define these and prove that
the polynomial P is not is not really
stable so now define Z J to be AJ T plus
BJ now because T has positive imaginary
value AJ is positive this would be a
complex number with positive imaginary
value so this says that the imaginary
value of Z is positive
furthermore P of Z 1 up to the n is
equal to P of 80 plus P and that's equal
to 0 so did so so now I get a root so
this is the root with in the in the
upper half complex plane so P is not P
is not really stable and that's the
contradiction
any question
okay so so let me let me give it another
view of this proof so let me show let me
describe an example consider this
polynomial 1 minus X Y this is a
bivariate polynomial let me draw its
roots in there in r2 so let's say this
is the X line this is the Y line if you
draw the roots of this do you see
exactly this picture is 2 would be
attention to the the X&Y line now if I
look at every every line pointing to the
positive words then it will cross the
set of roots at exactly two points so
this says that along every line pointing
to the positive more time if I restrict
my polynomial to that line I will have
exactly two roots and because the degree
of my polynomial is two this is that
these are exactly all of the roots so
this polynomial is reroute 'add along
every line point in the positive worst
and so this says that this polynomial is
real estate
so for another example consider this
polynomial 1 plus X Y let's draw the
roots of this again this is X this is y
the roots will be now you see there are
you can draw some lines to the path
divorce and that do not cross the roots
at all so even though this polynomial
has degree 2 there are some lines
porting pointing to the positive words
and where there are no roots in the real
space so you can draw there's not all
lines well okay so there are some lines
pointing to the positive words and such
that if you restrict upon your
polynomial along those lines you see no
roots so this polynomial is not real
stare so basically you should have this
picture in mind when I talk about real
estate polynomials you can basically
restrict to to RN you can draw the roots
of the polynomial and if the polynomials
we routed every every line pointing to
the positive words and crosses the set
of roots at exactly endpoints
not I want to say some examples
it's a example and not example we
already saw to 1 minus X law is an
example and 1 plus X law is a non
example so here's another one a 1 z 1
plus da da da plus a + Z n for a is
positive so this is a real estate
polynomial and they easy way to see it
is that suppose Z 1 up to the n have
positive imaginary value so you can
basically think about them as as vectors
in the in the positive half of the
complex plane so these are like Z 1 up
to the N now if a 1 up to a n are
positive I'm basically thinking of the
convex combination of these these
vectors pointing in the positive or
stand up to some normalization and any
convex combination of them also points
to the positive or that so this
polynomial cannot be 0 if Z 1 to Z n
have path imaginary value again a
non-example is z1 minus z2 you can just
assign both of them to BI and it's 0 so
it is not real stable
here is another one z1 z2 up to the N so
in fact you can see the product of any
two real estate polynomial is real
stable because the product of two points
of the product are just union of the
roots of the polynomials so this is a
real estate polynomial another one is
the elementary symmetric polynomial so
you take sum over all K the prod
but some of it all s in choose K of Z to
the s where I use this notation a lot
whenever I write Z to the s I mean
product of Z I for is so this is this is
called the case elementary symmetric
polynomial so for every K it turns out
that this polynomial is real stable I'm
not going to prove this now this is one
of the exercises we'll talk about it
after the update this lecture but this
is another example one more example any
so any univariate we are still
polynomial root okay so so this is a
again as fact simple to see again just
using the fact that the roots of a
polynomial with real coefficients come
in conjugate pairs you can easily prove
this if you have a polynomial if you're
univariate realness the polynomial has a
root we may get negative imaginary value
it must also have a root with positive
imaginary value therefore it's not
really a stable so if it is real stable
all of the roots should be on the real
one the one other non example is this
one Z 2 plus Z 3 4 so this is a non
example it's a it's important one you
can't you can actually plug in numbers
to prove that this is not a real
polynomial but I wanna know you know
instead of that I want to say one
theorem about real estate polynomial
which actually says the limitation of
this class of polynomials so
so there's a theorem of Hawaii later on
was strengthened by feather Brandon it
says that the support of any homogenous
lutea fine stable polynomial
I spawned okay
so I haven't defined what these two are
I'm gonna say it in a second but okay
this particular polynomial is either
homogeneous and mostly a fine and if you
look at that support the support is
really one two and three four and this
doesn't correspond to am a choice
because I mean okay I haven't defined
what I made sure I did you don't need to
know it for this talk but if you know
what it is a major it must have an
exchange property and this set doesn't
have exchange property so this doesn't
correspond to that to the real estate
partner I support I mean the set of
vectors that you see that you see a you
know a monomial with with those indices
just plot get that's get the set of
indices of of your polynomial now
there's a generalization of this which
again I don't have time to talk about it
but basically rather prove that that for
the general for a general real estate
polynomial the support is a jump system
so you actually know what are the
possibilities of the coefficients of a
real state polynomial let me just give a
definition for these two as well so
homogeneous if you haven't seen a
polynomial P is homogeneous if every
monomial of P have the same degree so we
say P is the homogeneous P of let's say
alpha Z 1 all the way to alpha Z n equal
to alpha to the D
so for example you know Z 1 Z 2 minus Z
G squared this is homogeneous to
homogeneous but 1 minus Z 1 is not
homogeneous
this has degree 0 this has degree 1 so
another definition again if you haven't
seen movie affine say P is moved here
fine it is Square free it's all
monomials I square free so for example
again Z 1 minus Z 1 Z 2 minus Z 3 cubed
is a non-example
but 1 plus Z 1 minus Z 1 Z 2 is an
example
so this polynomial for example either
square-free and is homogeneous
so
now okay so you already saw that this
realistic polynomials generalize the
class of reroute as polynomials now you
can ask and I already saw some example
yes any any any real step on the support
of any yet so the support of any real
estate polynomial is at the jump sister
so yeah so generally like similar to the
Yuans talk the way you work with these
polynomials is that you start from some
polynomial that you know is really
stable you do you apply some closure
properties that preserve these
polynomials until you get to the
polynomial of your interest now we can
there's always a question of where to
start
and typically in many of the proofs we
start from this particular determinant a
polynomial so I've heard this name from
Michigan mr. I think it's a good name
it's called mother of all Real Steel
polynomials so suppose suppose P is d by
D symmetric matrix a 1 up to a n D by D
St matrices then the polynomial
determinant of P plus 1 a 1 plus da da
plus Zn and is real state
so today we'll see a lot of examples
where we start from such a polynomial
and drive some other polynomials which
are real stable so let me prove this No
so that's not true so there are major
it's like the final mate right there
there are no so there is no real estate
polynomial whose support is the
correspond to basis of the van ami true
and this was again proved by Peter but
again in this workshop will see a
generalization of real state polynomials
called completely local K polynomials
where actually you can attain all
matrices as their support let me prove
this so the proof is by this lemma I
said a few minutes ago at I great so
basically I again look at this ad along
the lines to the positive or sin so
let's choose an arbitrary vector a in RN
it's every coordinate is positive and B
in RN let's look at let's look at the
terminus of V plus summation of a a I T
plus VI times a times a I this is my
polynomial I want to say this
polynomials real rooted and all I'm
going to use eventually is that is that
the characteristic polynomial of any
symmetric matrix has only real roots
okay
so so let me make my life easier look at
the ass yes suppose this matrices are
positive definite and in fact there
would be there would be a limiting
argument which extends this to all PSD
matrix well let me prove the easier
statement for a positive definite
matrices so suppose these areas are
positive definite so I can rewrite this
as follows this is equal to let me
factor out the coefficient of T this
coefficient of T is just summation of a
I AI plus so now what do I know I know
that a is are positive definite this
dinelli eyes are positive so this matrix
let's call it a is positive definite as
well it's it's a sum of positive
definite matrices I'd pass the positive
definite what do I have here B is
symmetric these are either symmetric
these are real number so this is
symmetric let's call this matrix C so so
all I have is just again this is really
determinant of a T plus C where a is
positive definite C is symmetric now
because a is positive definite it has an
inverse and a square root of inverse so
I can rewrite this as follows I can
rewrite it as determinant of a to the
one-half plus a to the minus 1/2 C a to
the minus 1 just factor out the a it's
the one half from both sides now I just
use the fact that the terminus of a B is
just the tenant of a time's the
determinant of B so I can take out this
a to the one half to the outside this is
equal to determinant of a times
determinant of C I plus a to the minus
1/2 C a to the minus 1/2 and that's all
basically this is just a number this
matrix
is a symmetric matrix because see
symmetric and this is just a a
multiplying a to the minus 1/2 to both
sides so this is a symmetric matrix this
is the characteristic polynomial of a
symmetric matrix so it must be real root
okay
so so now I get to the more interesting
part of this lecture which are called
the stability preservers already learned
what the sustain of polynomials are now
it turns out that there are a lot of
operators which preserve a stability
look if you start from from a real
estate polynomial I apply the operator
you're gonna get another a little pun on
and that's what we are going to learn
now so let me start with some so suppose
suppose we have a polynomial P so now
let's see some operators so here's the
simplest one let's look at P of to Z 1
comma Z 2 something this is real stable
and you know there are many easy ways to
see it basically if Z 1 has positive
imaginary value so is to 0 so this this
this map being X 2 to X maps upper half
complex plane to upper half complex
plane so so this polynomial is real
estate so you can do something the other
thing you can do for example Z 1 plus Z
2 comma Z 2 this is again the same thing
if Z 1 and Z 2 are positive imaginary
values so does Z 1 plus Z 2 you can
actually do something more interesting
we can apply we can do this can do a Z
plus P where where a is it says M by M
matrix that all coordinates of a are are
positive and B is a real vector
it's the same thing when you multiply a
V Z Z has positive imaginary value so is
a every row of every every every
coordinate of the vector that you get
will have positive imaginary back
so so so a special case of this a
special case of this is actually when a
is 0 I'm not not a 0 the first row of a
is 0 so something like this P of C comma
Z 2 up to the N where C is where the
imaginary value of C is positive is not
negative that's a special case and you
can see in this case yes it's kind of in
a special case because I'm assuming I
should I am here allowing a to be
non-negative and the way to see it is
that if if C has positive imaginary
value then this is of course true
because because because if if this has a
root the positive integer value so
that's the original thing now you can
take limits if to to get to the real
line and still the corresponding
polynomial will have will be real stable
okay
so this particular operation is very
useful for us it's called it's called
specialization so you can specialize not
only to numbers to publish imaginary
value but also to the real line and this
will be this would remain realistic it's
in particular yeah you can't you can
plug in C to be 1 or 0 and still have it
yes the polynomial will see a lot of
applications plug in 0 you also get this
oh yeah okay good so there's yeah
there's always a question of what you
should how you should treat the zero
polynomial my let's treat or that also
as a really good now okay so these are
some operations there are some more
interesting ones so differentiation so
if you look at partial Z one of P this
is a this is a stability preserver I
differentiate with respect to Z one this
this needs a little bit more work to
prove basically you need to prove the
God you need to use the Gauss Lucas
theorem
so remember Gauss Lucas theorem says
that if you have a univariate polynomial
the roots of a derivative are in the
convex hull of the roots of the original
part now basically you just need to use
that to prove that despawn I mean it's
real stable here is another one if you
look at P up minus one over Z 1 times Z
1 to the degree of V 1 this is again
another stability preserver operator and
again this what the proof is to see that
if you map X to minus 1 over X this maps
upper half complex plane to upper half
complex plane so so if Z 1 has past
imaginary values so does minus 1 over Z
1 and that's all now I can I can keep
going on writing more and more operators
but you can ask ok is there a general
picture like where is this going and
this has been xed started quite
extensively so there is this very nice
work of Porsha and Brandon
[Applause]
who actually characterize all all linear
operators that preserve real stability
now I'm not planning to say their
theorem in the most general way I want
to say some a special case of it which
is most useful so let me say that so let
t be operator which Maps polynomials is
even up to the end two polynomials
suppose it's defined as follows so T
equal to summation of I sum of all
vectors alpha and beta
these are integer vectors like
non-negative integer vectors so let's
suppose they are in into the end C of
alpha comma beta times Z to the Alpha
Harshal to the bit so let me say what I
mean by by this so this again this is e
to the Alpha is the same notation I kind
of uses so this is just product of Z I
to the hospitai
and this thing is product of partial zi
to the Beth I mean before continuing
this that means sure let me say some
examples so for example team could be
you know 1 minus Z van partial Z 2 plus
partial Z 3 squared you know - 3 4 and
so on okay so this is such an operator
okay so suppose you have such operator T
and the question is does this preserve I
apply this part this operator to a
polynomial P which is really stable
will the new polynomial be real stable
as well
now in order to answer that I need to
define a new thing so so now let's see
leti beat me this now define f of t
think of it as a symbol of T but this is
not really a symbol symbol is defined
differently but let's call it symbol of
T define it as follows summation over
again all alpha and beta integer vectors
alpha comma beta again I'm thinking of C
as a real number Z to the alpha minus W
to the pet so this this f of T is a new
polynomial in Zevon up to the N and W 1
up to W a so I'm gonna have n new
variables W 1 up to W n and it's I
define the rest of the symbol this way
wherever I have a wherever I have a
partial I substituted with you know
minus W of the same of the same index if
it's partial of I it's gonna be minus W
R okay so for example if you have this
F of F of this polynomial let's call
this call this Q Q is let's do the
exercise it's 1 minus Z 1 times minus W
2 plus minus W 3 squared minus 3/4 so
it's a very simple mechanical thing you
can do to construct this symbol okay so
now T is a stability preserver even only
if F of T is real stable
so that's the turret so for example let
me stay some example let's let's see one
minus partial Z one partial Z two like
one Operator
if I apply if I if I do the F thing this
is really 1 minus minus W 1 minus W 2
which is equal to 1 minus W 1 W 2 and
you already saw the beginning that this
is a real estate polynomial so this is a
stability preserve another example 1
plus partial Z 1 partial Z 2 so you do
the F thing again in this place you get
actually 1 plus W 1 W 2 and we saw this
one is not as stability preserver so
this one is not a real estate polynomial
so this is not a stability preserver
operator and you can ask why is this not
a stability preserver operator so in
this case it's easy to prove so if you
apply this if you apply this to Z 1 Z 2
you actually get 1 plus Z 1 Z 2 so so
even though this polynomial is really
stable but I apply it I get a non non
stable polynomial so this is not a 70
please never operate
question
so okay so first of all you can ask how
general is this theorem what kind of
operators can I kind of express this way
it turns out that it's it's very general
so so so basically any any linear
operator operator acting on Allah mules
of bounded degree
can be expressed can be can be expressed
this way
yes the inclusion meaning construction
of a few volumen I mean while the
partial build is replaced by your - yes
one one reason is that you want to be
able to apply to to z1 up to the end and
get
you want that to be realistic when you
apply it to do
good so let me
it's a particular operator called map so
this is called multi affine part so what
this operator does is that it only it
basically kills all monomials which are
not multi affine and only retains those
which are multi IFR
so so when you apply map for example to
say 1 plus Z 1 Z 2 minus 3 Z 3 squared
plus 2 squared basically I'm going to
kill the last two and this is equal to 1
+ 3 1 Z 2
that's what map does and there is a
simple lemma which again is exercise
that map is a stability preserver we're
going to use this theorem of Porsha
Brandon to prove that map is a stability
prisoner operates
any question
so now you have the machinery I can tell
you applications I wanted to say to
applications the first one is to prove
that the matching polynomial is real
routine and the second one is to design
an approximation algorithm for the
permanent of matrices with non-negative
entries so let me go to them so
application one matching polynomial its
mg of X 2 summation of K minus 1 to the
K X to the K M K and M K this is the
number of matchings of size k so the
claim is that this is real
I'm going to prove this using realistic
polynomials and stability preserver
operators let's prove it so basically
the proof is just two steps so first
let's start from this polynomial is to
get the product over all edges all I
never of J in the graph of 1 minus Zi Zi
J so this is again the family of
polynomial we saw many times that says
it's real estate it's real stable
I have product of real estate polynomial
so the product is also your stable so
this is the real polynomial now I apply
map to map of this product
stable as well because map is a
stability preserving operator
now let's think about what is the map of
this polynomial so here basically think
of Z is Z J as a generating polynomial
of the edge connecting I to J when you
open this up from every from every term
in the product you either choose the one
or you choose the edge you choose the
generating polynomial of the H now if I
if I choose two edges which are neighbor
of the same vertex I if I choose the ICJ
and maybe the i zk I'm gonna have a CI
squared or maybe a higher degree of I
depending on the rest of the edges and
map will will map that that that
monomial to 0 so a monomial will survive
only if all the edges that I choose
don't share any endpoints in other words
a monomial will survive if the edges
that I choose for my matching so so this
is so I can say this is exactly equal to
the summation over all matchings in my
graph minus 1/2 the size of the matching
the number of edges in the matching
times the product of zi for all vertices
I which are saturated in the matching
for all vertices I which you know have
an edge in the match so this is exactly
my my this is exactly what map does now
all you need to do is to just sort of
symmetric this polynomial replace all
the eyes with the same variable X this
remains real stable and this polynomial
is exactly equal to summation over K
minus 1 to the K X to the K this with
this becomes X to the K and then I have
M K because every matching of size K
will contribute 1 to the coefficient of
x to the K so so so I get that this
polynomial is really stable I already
said that any univariate real estate
polynomial must be real rooted so I get
the real root upon X to the 2k yes yeah
there was a 2
came here so this
so yeah so this is exactly equal to M G
of X I get that M G of X is real
so I think the arms forward are we learn
X to the N minus 2 K oh yeah yeah and
you can yeah if yeah you can also look
at X to the N minus 2 K but you can flip
the order of the course if the order of
the coefficients and remember that real
rooted polynomials would remain really
rooted when you reverse the coefficients
like X to the K is actually
I think exo-k is okay if this is real
good it is positive well I think there's
gonna be this is this has negative roots
this has negative to it because the
coefficients are positive if you raise
negative 1 to the K and replace to K by
K it's still real illusion right yeah it
is because the roots are positive and it
this is a polynomial of x squared if you
have all positive coefficients doesn't
work okay
good so let me say the second
application this is to approximate
permanent of matrices I have a matrix M
n by n matrix non-negative entries and
one approximate the permanence so first
let me remind you what the permanent is
is just the sum over all permutations
Sigma the product of M of I comma Sigma
I so that's a permanent it's a quantity
which is short be hard to compute the
best approximation algorithm that we
know is due to Gerard Sinclair and
recorder which which is polynomial time
which is randomized polynomial time it
gives one plus or minus epsilon
approximation to this quantity now there
is a no big open problem of if you can
get a good deterministic approximation
algorithm for this there's a lot of
there are a lot of works in this let me
briefly mention so there is a it's a
work of lineal some ordinates key and it
gets on from right and then little bits
from oh four and there's good with some
ordinates came from and then the newer
work of an Iranian resume T so basically
all these gives some constant an
approximation the best that we know at
the moment is root 2 to the n
approximation and it's open to get
better approximation algorithm
deterministically so this is again
deterministic
it's often to get by the approximation
deterministically I want to talk about
this result because it's quite short and
it actually has a lot of other
applications besides the permanence
so so here is a theorem of orbits so
stable with non-negative coefficients we
prove that if I take partial driven up
to partial the n of P is equal to 0 so
we differentiate P with respect to Z 1
up to the end and you evaluate it at 0
what this means is that they says this
is really the coefficient of the
monomials in 1 up to the end look at the
coefficient of this particular monomial
it is an approximated this way by
looking at the most P over Z 1 up to the
end for Z positive and e to the minus n
times the infimum of
it's sandwiched between this quantity
and e to the minus end of the same
quantity so if I can compute this
quantity I can approximate the
coefficient of Z 1 up to the end up to e
to the inner multiplicative so so why is
it useful application to per minute but
it's the application that P B so again
fix this fix this matrix M that's we
have you want to compute the per minute
let P be the be the product over I sum
over J of mi j zj so and the coordinates
of the entries of M are non-negative so
this is a realistic polynomial I have a
product of real state polynomials so
please real stable so and it also has no
negative coefficients again because of
em's are non-negative so I hope
polynomial P and the claim is that
basically coefficient of Z 1 up to the
end IP is equal to permanent of M so all
I need to do is to just compute this
this number and that's the that's a
permanent effect rate the way to see
this okay there are many ways to see
this you can you can basically see that
P is this product of this sums so if if
I want to get Z 1 up to the N I have to
choose one ZJ like exactly one ZJ from
each some and that corresponds to a
particular permutation which gives me
the you know to give me a z1 up to the
end monomial you can also do some
examples but I think that let me not
talk about the proof of this this is a
simple thing to check the identity so so
in order to approximate permanent all
you need to do is to approximate this
quantity and it turns out that you can
approximate this quantity just by a
convex program so
okay so this part this function is not
convict on its own but you can do a
change a variable and make it a convex
function so in particular if you look at
log of this function meaning log of P
over Z 1 up to the N where you do a
change of variables so you you
substitute CJ with e to the Y J so YJ is
really log of CJ so I look at P of e to
the Y 1 all the way to e to the Y and Y
1 log of this is really log of P of e to
the Y 1 minus y 1 minus 1 minus y so if
you look at this I claim that this is a
convex function of wise first of all the
second part is the linear term in wise
the first term is a convex function of F
wise because this is the idealogue some
X expression it's a log of summation of
Exponential's again I'm using that P has
non-negative coefficients so you can
really think of this as log of summation
of some Exponential's and so this is a
convex function this is a convex
function the sum of two convex function
is convex so this is kind of again you
can minute you can optimize this
quantity and that would give an e to the
approximation to 2 to the per minute
okay so so value of time let me so here
let me let me try to prove half of this
that I relate I leave part of the proof
for the exercise so so I want to prove
this this identity but half of it any
question so far
so okay so there are two sides to this
inequality this side is the easy side
and this side is the hard side so so
let's see the easy side actually you
don't need the polynomial to be
realistic you just need the polynomial
to have non-negative coefficients and
the reason is that okay I can I can
basically think of P of Z 1 up to the N
over v1 up to the n as follows I can
basically pull off the term which is
which is the coefficient of Z 1 up to
the n plus some extra this is really
that see I'm interested in in the middle
side this is the coefficient of Z 1 up
to the n then okay so this the division
is really C plus this extra stuff over Z
1 up to 0 and the thing is this is
non-negative because all coefficients of
P are non-negative and I'm evaluating
this quantity are non-negative reals so
this is non-negative so this is at least
C so for the right hand side you don't
really need P to be real stable it's
only that you need P to be real stable
for the left hand side improve the left
hand side
the proof is the proof is a simple sort
of okay it's a tricky but short
inductive argument so let's in induct on
n the number of variables let's prove
the base case let's talk about the base
case first the base case is when N
equals one so what let me let me write
it this is exactly the homework problem
they're sort of in-class exercise
problem so suppose you have a polynomial
f of a single variable T and F is real
rooted or real stable remember for
univariate real rooted annual step are
the same so it's really a non-negative
coefficients f Prime at 0 is at least 1
over e times the infimum of F at T over
T this is really the this is really the
same the same thing except when n is
equal to 1 this e to the minus n becomes
e to the minus 1 ok so ok so I'm not
going to prove this I will prove it in
the exercise section but let's take this
for granted and now let's do induction
so I want to induct an end so this is
the base case
now they find you to be partial Z and of
P at the N equals zero so I just killed
up one variable now I have Q Q has n
minus 1 variable so Q is only on Z 1 z 1
up to the N minus 1 but only n minus 1
variables therefore I can I can use
induction hypothesis applied on and Q
remember that so remember that Q is
really stable right because all I did is
that I I differentiate and specialize
and both of these operations preserve
realist ability
so yeah so this and this are stability
preserver q is real stable it has not
negative coefficients again you can see
because I mean this is the
differentiation and plugging in non
negative values will preserve
non-negative coefficients so I can apply
induction hypothesis to Q so by
induction hypotheses partial Z want up
to partial Z and minus 1 of Q at 0 at
least 1 over e to the N minus 1 of
infimum of Q over is even after the okay
that's the induction hypothesis now yes
I claim that this thing is exactly you
cost the left left hand side this is
really partial Z 1 up to partial Zn of p
0 q remember q was just differentiating
p at the n and then evaluating at 0 and
i'm just changing the order of
differentiation and substitution but
these are these up operators or
commutable
so you can change the order so this is
really called left hand side and i want
to relate this to the right hand side so
here's like what I do yeah let's say I
assume that this infimum is attained at
some point I'm cheating a little bit but
let's do that you really need to do
epsilon Delta argument but let's make
the argument simply so suppose this is
equal to 1 over e to the N minus 1 of Q
of everyone star n minus 1 star where is
e 1 star so I'm I'm assuming that this
infimum is attained at Z 1 star up to
the N minus 1 star
now one more step
so now define f to be P of Z 1 star so
it's a univariate polynomial f of Zn to
be P of Z 1 star up to the N minus 1
star so I I specialized to as we wanna
start up to Zn minus 1 star again again
F is real rooted and non-negative
coefficients because I just a
specialized to non-negative numbers and
this is e 1 star F to the N minus 1 z n
minus 1 star non-negative so f is really
than a negative coefficient so I can
apply this this base case again to F so
I get that basically F Prime at 0 is at
least 1 over e times infimum of f of z n
over z
that's just bye-bye again by the by the
by the base case
now f Prime at 0 is equal to exactly
this quantity to Q of Z 1 star up to the
N minus 1 star because remember F is
just differentiating this with respect
to the end cut sorry F prime of 0 is
just differentiating this with respect
to the N at 0 and that's exactly Q of Z
1 star of Z minus 1 so this is equal to
that now you're almost done now divide
both sides by Z 1 star up to the N minus
1 star
then yeah then this is this is equal to
1 over e times infimum of now i i
replace f vp right this is really p of
civil star up to DN minus 1 star come as
the end over is e 1 star Zn minus 1 star
how much the end and in a few moments
all the others yet but now I can take
the in few moment of you over all of
these and I call it that can only make
it smaller so this is bigger than really
call to one over e times the infimum
over all Zevon up to the end to be non
negative of P of Z 1 up to the end where
Z 1 up to see I get one about you from
here all the way to the end - not from
there over time but let's stop here
there are no questions so you can so
there is this class of polynomials so
you can you can work with e to the end
itself that's not really a polynomial
but of a bounded degree but but if you
plug that in that would actually give
you work with e to the Z 1 plus Z 2 up
to the n that would preserve all
properties appears there polynomials and
it will be titled
yes you can track it yeah yeah yeah but
yeah you can you can get truncated but
yeah if you want to be very careful but
usually that would give you a tight
example for many of these things here
okay that would make it a little bit
more
[Applause]